you have any plans to return back to the
superhero genre have you been approached
can you see yourself returning to uh a
reunion of arrow or doing something in
the superhero world or have you not been
approached by any of that or would you
consider it if you were um if i had been
approached i wouldn't say but i have not
i think way away no no no okay i know it
made sense
you know i was i was thinking about this
question as i as i drove here
and um
if
if the opportunity ever came up to like
do
[Music]
six to eight episodes of arrow as like a
limited series
on netflix or hbo max or
something like that where
or on the cw as the case may be
i think that'd be amazing
so you'd do it if it was a limited
series sort of like street either
streaming or under 10 episodes that was
doable
and you would do something like that
uh no i actually wouldn't put a limit on
it at all i think the idea of
of
coming back and
playing oliver queen at any point in my
life
is a really fun idea um the example
being
like
you know michael keaton's about to be
[ __ ] batman again yes he is i'm gonna
be happier it has been
29 years
since he played batman
it's been like six and a half minutes
since i played
since i played arrow i know i know i
know i love i love i love playing oliver
queen
and
and just in general the idea of like
going going back to that character as
i'm getting all these new reps
as an actor and feel like i'm getting i
feel like i'm getting better
i mean that's it's in it's intoxicating
but it
from you know
hand to god i have not been approached
at all
you